ce langage qu'on vient d'entendre celui
que celui qui est le langage de vos
chansons et avec lequel vous exprimer
d'ailleurs même en dehors de vos
chansons
il correspond à quoi il correspond à une
mode que vous avez essayé de capter ou
c'est le vôtre que vous essayez
d'imposer au sort est beaucoup plus
facile c'est si j'avais juste à capter
une mode
non c c'est plein de choses que j'aime
bien
il ya des flashes de cinéma et des
réminiscences de rock
alors justement j'ai fait j'ai fait de
les laisser avec une chanson par exemple
un texte de prévert ou une chanson de
charles aznavour lorsqu'on met à plat
une chanson de prévert ou une chanson de
charles aznavour ou georges brassens
si on la lit simplement ça donne quand
même un poème qu'il est facile de
comprendre
et puis lorsqu'on met à plat une chanson
de vous par exemple ou bien nous
l'avions fait avec une chanson d'alain
souchon s'aperçoit souvent qu'ils
allaient phrases sans verbe des éléments
comme ça et que le texte ne veut pas
forcément dire quelque chose comme ça en
lisant ou les je peux vous lire un
extrait par exemple d'une chanson qui
s'appelle reviens vatan si je le lis
comme ça ça fait ça donne ta prenez au
mainate le pont de la rivière kwaï dans
le zoo j'étais encore épouvantail
revient vatan toujours à fuir mogador
les jours de paella surtout pas griller
la gitane viva españa je ne sais pas
aussi évident que ça c'est la chanson
peut-être la plus fantaisiste comme dans
l'album parce que de toute manière un
texte de chanson il doit être fait pour
être chantée d'abord et les parent doit
pas être fait pour être lu parce que on
peut très bien avoir un texte superbe
qui va rien donner du tout chanter ou
alors ça va être leur faut se diriger
vers brassens parce que il fait des
jolies phrases enfin ces deux choses
différentes
moi je vois plutôt le rapport
orchestration voix et et émaux enfin je
fais une espèce de puzzle comme ça où
chacun fait un peu sa chanson c'est à
dire ce que vous voulez quand même
donner un sens à la chanson vous écrivez
que vous chantez vous quel sens qu'elle
semble je veux surtout pas donné un seul
sens parce que ça et vite pour éviter
l'ennui un peu parce que y'a rien de
plus ennuyeux pour moi que d'entendre
une chanson est d'avoir compris
exactement tout ce que voulait dire le
type de la première strophe
oui enfin en sachant carrément la rime
qui va suivre
ça m'intéresse pas du tout ce je crois
que sans ce livre est une grande étude
des paroles de vos chansons je crois
qu'il ya une chose d'abord qui saute aux
yeux c'est l'humour je craque pour la
première fois depuis longtemps
vous faites de la musique du rock'n'roll
avec de l'humour
tout à l'heure on était tous à sourire
en écoutant les paroles de gaby et en
particulier parce que vous employez des
images plus qu'un sens direct d'ailleurs
un des paroles et les images qui font
sourire
cochonnet connaissant les boules le
pétard qui a besoin d'une allumette à
propos d'une des deux jeunes femmes web
penser aux problèmes aux pétards y a
plusieurs sens au mot pétards calpétard
14 juillet il ya le pétard de la dame
qu'on a envie de toucher il ya le pétard
qu'on fume et la tête d'autres encore je
voyais alors alors qui est mélangé tout
ça c'est ça qui est à ce moment mais
alors ce qui est le gage que vous avez
tapé juste c'est que par exemple chez
les ch et enfants en ce moment le
langage de vos chansons on le retrouve
dans les cours des lycées dans la cour
des écoles crois que ça va dans les deux
sens mais je crois que oui les enfants
sortent parfois des trucs qui sont pas
ce qu'on pourrait dire c'est le langage
de votre génération mais vous n'êtes pas
de très éloigné de ma génération on a
des âges qui se rejoignent et donc vous
n'êtes pas forcément quelqu'un qui a été
à l'école l'année dernière et qui a pris
sa ces textes là et ses expressions là
dans la cour du lycée ou non c'est donc
c'est venu vraiment de fantasme qu'on a
eus ensemble et qu'on a essayé de
reproduire comme ça et je vous dirai
twitter c'est vraiment un puzzle on
entend un mot comme ça ou une phrase et
or on voit un petit peu des situations
qui se suivent comme ça et on se fait sa
propre chanson mais chacun va retrouver
dans votre texte des différentes et
l'ouvrir en sens bien sûr parce qu'il ya
même un côté complètement désespéré
aussi de temps en temps et elles mêmes
des lignes qui cache des choses assez
grave
ça m'ennuie un petit peu de parler de
choses graves au premier degré parce que
je trouve qu'on est plutôt là pour faire
pour distraire pour et en foot la tête
comme ça dans dans le caca je trouve ça
un petit peu dur enfin
[Musique]